jetzt habe ich die große ehre donald
trump zum dritten mal in folge den
goldenen vollpfosten zu verleihen
das hat vor ihm wirklich noch keiner
geschafft was für einen laufbahn sind
gut
schon jetzt gab es für trump diese woche
einen kleinen rückschlag in alabama wo
trumps kandidat verloren hat nur weil er
geisteskrank ist und kleine mädchen
marken
nur ein typ der mitten im wahlkampf
gerne geladene knarre zieht und der
homosexuelle hast kurz ein kandidat den
tramp einfach unterstützen musste ja hat
nicht geklappt dumm gelaufen aber
insgesamt das müssen wir fairerweise
sagen insgesamt war es natürlich donalds
jahr oder 2017 wahnsinn wahnsinn was der
tramp alles nicht geschafft hat
möglicherweise gelingt ihm auf den
letzten metern noch eine steuerreform
wobei das ist natürlich nicht irgendeine
reform bvg so alter ich habe so eine
steuerreform verstehst du bei denen
klingt alles irgendwie unanständig
findet der größte präsident aller zeiten
quasi der grillplatz
62 prozent der steuererleichterung die
er versprochen hat betreffend übrigens
die reichsten ein prozent der amis
schreibens familie spart eine milliarde
niedrigerer einkommen werden kaum
entlastet und müssen wahrscheinlich
demnächst sogar mehr zahlen ja ist nicht
schön in den usa arm zu sein
manche haben sogar kein geld für ein
ordentliches gebiss gehören sich immer
genau hin
immer passieren
trump hat kein gebiss das sind
alternative szene
meine damen und herren aber wo er gerade
was von israelische der edith schief er
wollte jetzt einfach mal ganz spontan
rausfinden wie in seinem experiment was
eigentlich passiert wenn man jerusalem
als hauptstadt von israel anerkennt
nicht nur gutes wie sich herausstellt
alles was dieser typ an wahnsinn auch zu
hause habe ich das mitgekriegt damit in
utah im bundesstaat utah mehr gefragt
werden kann
ich weiß das ja
damit da mehr gefragt werden kann werden
naturschutzgebiete drastisch verkleinert
ist dem vogel die umwelt eigentlich
völlig egal
liefern lidl bekenntnis stilistischen
und bisher umwelt können wir lassen ein
bisschen kann stehen bleiben sie als
kulisse
mein gott die new york times hat jetzt
enthüllt der präsident der vereinigten
staaten glotzt jeden tag mindestens vier
stunden fernsehen
wahnsinn manchmal 56 stunden wieso hat
er dafür die zeit und nach wie vor
weigert sich trump wohl längere dossiers
zu lesen das maximum sind lauter times
ganz ganz kurze briefings wo man
versucht ihnen die wesentlichen dinge zu
erklären aber so simpel wie möglich in
dem kurzen zeitfenster das man hat hier
geht es jetzt zum beispiel um den
nahostkonflikt
und wenn trump ist schafft zwei minuten
aufzupassen kriegt er zur belohnung ein
eis und da fernsehen gefährlich ist wenn
damals läuft was er nicht versteht
sprechende schwämme oder so das macht
ihm angst und damit natürlich wirken
sehr klar
anyway meine damen und herren die
heute-show verleiht donald trump den
vollpfosten 2017 und zwar in der
kategorie unermüdlicher kampf für den
weltfrieden
herzlichen glückwunsch